but i don't know because i get this like
anxiety and i just think that would give
me anxiety
like knowing that he hooked up with one
of my friends i found out oh one of my i
found out that a girl i was seeing one
time
had slept with like one of my friends
it's a rap for me no but it was
so far down the line
that we were like getting we got into a
relationship because i didn't tell one
of my boys
we got into a relationship
and then like one day we're having a
conversation and she was just like
oh yeah this guy used to know called
so-and-so and i was like okay cool and
she said she said the area and i was
like
oh um
does he drive this car she was like yeah
and i was like
did you sleep with him she was like yeah
oh that's different yeah okay and i was
like
[ __ ] that's one of my boys
oh [ __ ] i was like
no are you serious i was like yeah
that's my proper close guy like oh
really and she was like
do you guys like compare notes no but i
was like
what can you do if you've started a
relationship with this person i think at
that point do you know what i'm saying
what did you do afterwards we continued
what was that conversation like like
what was what i was like brother
i need to i see you man she's like yeah
i went round and i was like you know her
and he was like yeah yeah
and i was like
you used to see it right and he was like
yeah i said how long ago
and he was like over like a year and a
half ago
okay cool my boy is going to tell me he
doesn't know that i'm with her already
like yeah was that wrong that that's my
girl you know
and he was like
serious he was like he's serious i was
like yeah he was like
oh
he was that brother i'm sorry i said
there's nothing to apologize for
and i was like you know what kind of
involved bro like what kind of like
he's like do your thing yeah yeah i
think if it was a long time ago because
i'm only like i'm only 25.
so i was thinking if it was a long time
ago maybe and if the other person was
like married or something
right yeah
you're like zero chance for it to happen
again
yeah
but if it was a long time yeah if it was
a long time ago and like in that like if
she was married you know and it wasn't
yeah i probably or maybe just dropped
the front yeah
i think i think but he can't
my rule for me is
as long as her body count is less than
mine
that's what i've noticed with a guy but
you might have like 500 bro she might
have 200.
that's true but i don't have that but no
because i don't i don't just i think if
you
it sounds really wanky
like i wouldn't just
i don't just sleep with girls that i
find attractive like that anymore i used
to be like that but then it got to a
point where i'm like
i value my sexual energy right
do you know what i mean
it's a thing yeah and it sounds
lame but like some people just don't
deserve your sexual energy it's not lame
it's about
you more so than them yeah do what
people do when you say that is he gay
he must be funny hey no no the thing is
i get what you're saying yeah totally
get what you're saying but people start
with like oh my god is he gay that whole
shame
guilt
that old sign language thing comes in
because women want to know
most women haven't been rejected right
especially sexually yeah
and when they do they just they go in
they go in they go in when they get
sexually rejected
oh you must be you must be gay don't you
don't you think women feel entitled
to what
everything
i'm so serious because like i feel like
men do anything for for women nowadays
and it's like
oh i was on the i was on the train the
other day
and you know when you're coming off the
train
then people gotta come move out your way
so you can yeah because you got a girl
you know what i'm saying so they can get
on
there's a woman in like in the mid in in
front of me
in like the door's open she's standing
right on the track and i'm looking at
her like and bear in mind there's loads
of people i'm looking at like blood like
everyone's waiting
for you to move because we've got gas
here at the office i'm off the train
bro she didn't move she didn't
move she just she looked me dead in my
eye i was like
i said that blood like i'm not gonna
move so i just went away i was like all
right cool and i've
that happened and it's mad because i
found that
when i realized that that happened to me
i started looking out for it because in
my head i was like
because in that moment i feel cause she
was she was uh she was a nice woman by
the way yeah she was a very attractive
woman in my head i was thinking
these women think they'd own the world
cool
walked up the road now at my map where i
live
you know when like you might be walking
up the road and like there's bushes here
so you kind of gotta move from the
bushes right yeah cool i'm moving
and the woman's obviously coming this
way
and she's not moving out my way bear man
she can see the bushes as well yeah and
i'm trying to move forward
you know what i'm saying
you know what i'm saying
like what do you expect me to wait for
you like i got [ __ ] to do too late but i
think they feel entitled man like to a
lot of things to a lot of things man
and i do feel like it's mental if that's
yeah it's men's fault
y'all like who do you think made them
like this true it's not women
like men really did sympt for women yeah
for decades didn't they like yeah but i
said on your last show
the reason why they've done it is
because they were asked to do it because
men essentially want to get women i
think it's kind of natural to guys to be
honest i think men want to help women
like if i
i um and if they ask you for something
you're going to want to you're going to
want to help them
even even like wait what'd you say
oh jesus
no like i've had guys help me with just
like random stuff over the years like
fixing a tire or like like whatever you
know
so random guys are guys you know
both okay
but i think i think because
so statistically speaking
99 of women have reproduced historically
but only like 38 of men have
i thought it was 40 and 80 now
what women who are reproducing
i thought i was 80 and 40 man oh i've
heard it's like 99 oh really you might
be right i don't know but so women
reproduce like like most of them for
most women like reproduction is
it's not it's like not even a thing that
can't happen for them what does that
mean does that mean that the 40 of men
are reproducing with the
sorry with the 99 of women yeah so
generally like
only 30 to 40 of men like father
almost all the children historically
so polygamy is a thing then it's always
been a thing yeah
so you know how we're saying what's
happening now is it's going back to what
the way it works it's interesting but
but the reason i'm raising that is
because you know we're saying so most
men don't reproduce
historically
so imagine how many people are having
sex with their cousins and like
long-distance cousins and they don't
even know no but it's like okay
but i think but think of it this way
right if
let's say one word let's say a woman can
only bear the children of one man
right right
if a man has kids with four different
women
that's four different guys that will
never have kids
do you see what i'm saying ah yeah yeah
if if
because if you say because you should
have left that for another guy sperm is
cheap
eggs are valuable if a woman gets
pregnant she can't get pregnant for nine
months
and especially because we know
instinctually women would rather share
the top guy
sexually
than have the bottom guy to herself
back then like i said there wasn't birth
control so if she got pregnant yeah she
was tied to that guy forever yeah yeah
she got his child
but the reason the main the original
reason why i was raising that point
about
you know in terms of who's reproduced in
in the past is because there's something
new today men have always had to fight
for women as in to get access to women
they've always had to fight because
there's no guarantee that they'll worry
about
yeah they're not going to yeah they'll
get their genes into the next generation
so this whole kind of simple behavior or
no we're just simply but guys wanting to
yeah
it's very natural in us because we have
to fight for our genes to make it
especially when you're
told
by women this is what if you want to get
if you want to get it yeah that's what
you do yeah
you want to get it this is what you do
and so like i said this on the last show
like
women
told guys what they want
guys became those guys
and now women don't want those guys yeah
they're well
i also think
men are more
feminized a little bit yeah partially
partially because i thought i was gay
yeah she first met me
she thought you were gay yeah she
questioned if i was gay i said that
because is that because you're an actor
yeah i mean i'm a creative person so
that's quite you know feminine qualities
and creative openness and stuff like
that you know what i mean i think this
is your world spot
maybe i don't know maybe but also as
well like i was like one of the only
guys who didn't hit on her she was she
was like he must be gay
maybe
some girls i'm like have you never been
humbled maybe it's because i grew up
between two boys i've been humbled a
time or two
i don't just assume every guy i meet
like wants to sleep with me you know
what i mean yeah but if you think if you
think for every 100 guys who want to
sleep with you only one doesn't
huh i don't get it so like so you may
meet one guy who doesn't want to sleep
with you
but for every one guy who doesn't
there's probably a hundred there's 99
that will do you know what i mean yeah
so then
that one that's not that's not a very
humbling time yeah that gives you so
much gas